[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qui vous amène ici ce
soir je suis consultant en art c'est
quoi exactement
willy sutton cambrioleurs de banques
accompli et maître de l'évasion
pourquoi brac est il des banques sutton
a répondu parce que c'est là où est
l'argent
[Musique]
si ce taux n'avait vécu à notre époque
il n'aurait pas cambrioler les banques
il aurait braqué les riches je suis très
impressionné bingo je vais pas faire ça
toute ma vie tu vas en faire de plus en
plus après finissent mal adorable ton
père était en contact mois pendant
longtemps j'ai la nette impression que
tu essaies de nettoyer les maires de
papa tue c'est en syrie je crois que
c'est dans l'autre sens je voulais
demander qu'est ce que tu me racontes et
bien je veux en être moi c'est
marguerite
je m'appelle carré et élise amusez vous
bien les enfants
[Musique]
c'est un coup petits adorent merci
pourquoi vous priver fbi en trois ans
vous et vos hôtes vous avez récolté plus
de 75 millions de dollars en vendant sur
le marché gris de fruits vol qu'est ce
que vous voulez c'est un gros tu me fais
un dernier job un truc facile et ce sera
fini toi et moi on sera vite c'est quoi
tes options mes options sous mourir ou à
mourir
ok j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont un truc
que tu me dis pas d'une nonne vous ferez
une connerie
ce sera peut-être pas vous souviendra
peut-être d'une très instable copines ou
d'or petit frère bipolaire mais il y a
toujours une faille
qu'est ce que tu penses de faire une
minute de cers
[Musique]
elle va durer combien de temps tu as
minutes là dessus